you know what it was like the perfect
storm i answered the call i played
around i had fun i didn't take life too
serious and it turned into this
really fun joke that touches with a lot
of people because
everyone's gotten the wrong number and
so i'm yes i'm always flattered do i
think i'm the greatest community in the
world
hell no but do i love that it's a really
solid joke and could be one of the
greatest jokes ever told
yeah bro a lot of work goes into a short
late night stand-up set
join me jp buck as i spotlight the
comedians who came up with some of my
favorite coin sets
this is the setup please welcome back to
the show the very funny
jay larsen
[Music]
you know i've worked with late night
bookers on craig ferguson and
on carson daly and the whole thing has
always been
uh it has to be quick jokes in case
someone tunes in
and they see the set you could never do
a long story do you remember how long we
tried to get this set
to a time that worked you were gonna
take a chance and we couldn't do it
and then finally you were like let's do
it and every comedian comes to me all
the time and they're like
one of the greatest sets of all time on
late night and i'm like i know and
doing a story remember we tried it the
second time it didn't go as well
for an audience that's in the room if
they don't get on board right away
you're not going to get them later and i
hadn't even thought of that never once
did that cross my mind you know the
first time it crossed my mind
kumel said to me he goes man that conan
said and i'm like oh thanks man he goes
did you what would you have done at two
minutes in they hadn't like
gotten bored and i was like dude i
never even thought of it like i just
never thought of it because i love that
story so much
that like i'm not saying it's never not
worked
but like it's never not worked when you
sent it to me
it was timing out at about six and a
half
minutes maybe longer yeah at that early
stage i mean every late night set i did
before this one was like
4 20 4 30. and for your audience like
you got to be exactly we're on tv this
isn't like at a club where they're like
let's go
and they're flashing the light it's like
you gotta get off if you go long
we're going to have to cut something out
and they're going to watch this set
finish and it's not going to make any
sense
yeah or you're going to have to ask
conan to cut from his monologue and
what i have a question
your cell phone rings and you don't
recognize the number what do you do
ignore it don't answer it not me i like
life
the other day my cell phone rang 917.
that's a new york number i didn't know
who it was i messed up my words there
you could tell i'm a little nervous i
say rank 9-1-7
i'm not basically i'm saying i didn't
know who it was so right then and there
like i'm like just get past it just
because if you know
jp as a as a booker and as a stand-up
you can stand in the back of the room
watch a comic
do a joke you know and you can see the
tiniest miss
just the tiniest little word that no one
in the room will notice but you will see
the laugh
at the end of that joke not hit as hard
this is the story so i
i can recover but that was like i was a
little nervous you know
i picked it up anyway i hit talk i said
hello guy in the line goes hey bruce
what's going on
my name's jay not bruce so i said
nothing much man what's going on with
you he said
i'll tell you what's going on i just got
an email about the budget it's supposed
to be fifteen
thousand now it's ten thousand and i'd
like to know what's up
i got excited in my chest i grabbed the
steering wheel i was like okay focus
your name is bruce there's a budget it
was fifteen thousand now it's ten
thousand no one's happy about it
that's all we know that's all we know
when i go
my name's jay not bruce it's like the
audience is a little bit like all right
what's gonna happen like what's
i can feel it and i always know where
they are and that's what i love about
stand up is you're like
just hold oh my gosh you know what i
mean and like
right here at this moment everyone
swarms in when you grab the steering
wheel
so i just repeated back to him what he
said to me and i go ten thousand it's
supposed to be fifteen thousand
he goes yeah i know well i just got an
email and now it's ten
i go listen man i don't know what to
tell you i've been on the road all day
you know i haven't even seen it and he
goes
did you send this out give him some
attitude to bruce
i didn't like it that's like my favorite
thing in the whole joke yeah is like i
didn't even like the way he talks to bru
like i'm stepping up for
i said listen man the budget was fifteen
thousand we had a couple extra
expenditures it went up to sixteen
two i reworked it got it down to
fourteen seven
i had three hundred to play with so i
called it fifteen and i sent it out
and he goes yeah well now it's ten man
and i was like oh my god that worked
that worked
phase one complete phase one complete
like now i'm in the door i have a 401k i
was at the christmas party okay
that's one of my favorite lines which
one i've been at the christmas party
that's a sickler that's sickler yeah
stand-up is such an individual thing
it's you alone but
in comedy clubs when you get off stage
it's hanging out with other comics and
you're getting ideas and
that was one of them it used to be like
i had a 401k because this didn't happen
in the call this is everything
afterwards
yeah you know i mean i think in the
longer version i go uh
like i i was at the christmas party like
yeah i got a little tipsy and stole a
toy for todd
you know something like along those
lines that just was like that doesn't
matter but it's fun yeah
so he goes did larry okay this i go
listen man
i took the budget to larry larry said it
looked fine but i knew it was my ass on
the line
so i ran it by jennifer just in case
just to double check jennifer said it
looked good
i sent it out he goes yeah well now it's
ten
man and i realized this guy has no idea
what's going on over there
he hasn't talked to larry i know he
hasn't talked to bruce he doesn't even
recognize my voice
i know he didn't talk to jennifer i just
made her up
so that's the only thing that's not real
okay
jennifer i literally made her up and
made her up
my guy is so thorough that he didn't
just run it by larry
he ran over to jennifer too just to you
know see how it went
so he goes listen man what are we gonna
do about this and i go listen
i'm on the road right now i haven't even
seen the email why don't you give larry
call check in with him see what he says
call me back just praying he will
because that return phone call was going
to be amazing
that's where i thought this whole thing
would end he would hang up call the guy
call me back and be like who is this
dude that's why i thought it was gonna
end
i get home i'm so excited i take out my
cell phone i'm like you know what i'm
gonna save that guy's number
give him a call in a couple days touch
base you know what i mean check it
see where we're at you know so i save it
in my phone under random guy
that's what he is he's a random guy four
or five days pass i forget about it
laying on my couch watching the ball
game phone rings in the dining room
table
i get up watching the game grab the
phone watching the game look down
random guy but it's been a couple days
you know what i mean so i'm like random
guy who's random guy
like who would even have random guy as
their name that comes up
and then i was like random guy
like now i'm panicked you know what i
mean people's lives have been affected
it's only five grand but i don't know
how big that company is
but i'm addicted to it you know what i
mean i started this thing i need to see
it through
this physicality of you going back to
the phone like i love this miming
it's not really 100 literal
i'm so careless with people's worlds
that i just even forgot it was happening
and now i'm like oh my god before it was
you know just the call before it was a
number now
it's a name it's personal like this
something has happened and now i'm gonna
have to face the music i don't know who
they are but i was still scared you know
what i mean
and i do remember i like put my earbuds
in because i just needed to like move
around you know what i didn't want it
here it was too close
so i put my earbuds in just get a little
distance you know just see a little
space
and i hit talk same guy goes hey larry
what's going on
yeah now he's calling me larry he knows
something's up but i'm not about to back
down i go nothing much man what's going
on with you
and he goes well i got us on conference
call with janelle
and marie and i was like okay here we go
here we go
this is why we play the game you guys
this is why we play the game
so i go welcome to the call ladies as if
to say welcome to the show you know what
i mean here we go
marie takes the lead she goes hey larry
what time is it where you are i live in
l.a they're in new york it's 5 30. so i
go
8 30 it's 8 30. she was really what's
the weather like and i was like oh
weather's nice
weather's nice she goes you know this
doesn't sound like larry
and i go oh yeah who's it sound like and
a random guy chirps him from the back
and he goes
sounds like bruce sounds like bruce
like he's gonna blow this case wide open
that was sickler too i used to say and
that guy chirps him from the back and
ryan was like
why don't you say random guy so like you
because it's like he is in the back like
in the conversation and he did like
chirp in
and now if there's any videos online of
me
there's always a comment somewhere that
says this sounds like bruce
and i go listen guys this isn't larry
and it isn't bruce
and marie goes who is this
i said i'm just some guy who had nothing
better to do than to mess with you guys
and marie got pissed she was not happy
she was you understand we're trying to
run a business over here
i was like yeah well i got that from the
budget i just figured it was a business
segment
and she goes what do you think this is
some kind of joke and i was like a
little bit thought it's pretty funny
that's pretty funny and she goes let me
ask you something and i go
no you let me ask you something and she
goes what and i go
where are we at with the budget
the number the larry guy the guy who the
guy random guy
yeah he owns a scrap metal yard
in new jersey okay
and he volunteers his accounting
knowledge
to a foundation in los angeles
that sends jewish people to cuba
this was before you could go to cuba and
he
volunteers his time to help them with
like budgets or like whatever
and he dialed one number wrong somewhere
in my number and their number
and got me and then that's just all that
happened so i asked him like
would you do it like i want to do a mini
documentary like with him
with uh the two women you know what i
mean with larry with bruce
like get everyone together and like find
out what happened and he was like
nah man
[Laughter]
you were accused of stealing this [ __ ]
yeah um did you want would you care to
address those accusations
so i did this video with these glasses
on
and a little beard on laugh factory
i mean i just look different i have a
beard and glasses and i'm thinner
and then in that i'm clean shaven
and when i did it they used to like pull
clips and post them right
so when i did it i said hey please don't
post this i want to do it on late night
and they were like okay
and then after like eight months or ten
months one day i'm driving
and my phone starts like getting it's
like buzzing you know
i'm seeing like all these like youtube
like subscribers popping up blah blah
blah i'm like what is going on
and then someone's like just saw your
thing on laugh factory and i was like
what and i called the booker laugh
factory i'm like hey
i do not want that what is going on like
i don't want that video up i'm going to
use that on late night she's like oh my
god i'm so sorry we just put it up blah
blah blah i'm like oh yeah can you
please take it down
and she goes yeah but it has 120 000
views and it's only been up for like 12
minutes
and i was like oh i'm like hey you can
leave it up you know
can we by the way can we note or do we
know does anyone have the stats
is this not the most viewed ever conan
in the history of conan i'd have to talk
to my digital team i just want to know
[Music]
you'll be very happy to hear that tanner
rosenberry says that was like a seinfeld
episode
this is my life in a nutshell i did an
episode of curb last year
okay january of 2020 the year was
looking good
and in between takes
all i wanted to do was get friends with
larry so we could talk about
this so i could find a way that he would
see this and be like that's a good joke
but me being me and i can't back away
from something that i think is funny
in between takes we're hanging out and
he's practicing his golf swing with
no club right mm-hmm and i can't help
myself dude
i go up i put my hands on his hips i'm
like larry you gotta
you gotta power these hips through the
zone man you gotta turn
and he oh he did not like that
he did not like me touching him and he
just went
and walked all the way back to video
village and and didn't come back till we
shot again
and i was just like oh for for like 10
minutes i was like what'd you do you're
gonna get fired today
and then i was like you know what that
this is gonna be an episode of curb
in like two years you know what i mean
it's gonna be a moment
and so i was like this is why i do life
to see what'll happen and i took a swing
and he didn't love it i did
i was like special guest feature for
bobcat
at cobbs in san francisco saturday night
bobcats sitting there on his phone and
he just goes before the early show when
he goes uh
rob williams come the show tonight he
also said he googled you today and
watched your wrong numbers story five
times said it's one of the best jokes
he's ever heard
and i go shut your goddamn mouth dude
because rob williams is my idol dude
show ends
i'm gonna go out and shake hands say
goodbye to people and as i'm sitting
there
someone comes up and puts their hands on
my shoulders and i look right here and
it's robin williams and he goes
that wrong number joke my wife and i
watched it five times one of the best
jokes i've ever seen
i almost cried i was like oh my god
thank you thank you
thanks so much man and i just went and
said goodbye to people and then went up
in the green room and of course rob
williams is in the green room
and there'd be a joke floating around
before you even
when you thought of it he was saying it
he was grabbing everything
and all he you could feel the attention
goes right to him
and anytime it fell on him he would go
hey bobcat remember and he'd throw it to
bobcat
like this is your green room this is
your it was unreal dude
i'd never seen anything like that it was
so unselfish
like he couldn't help get the attention
and then he just made it about bobcat
and then we get ready for the second
show and uh
you know i'm like all right i'm gonna go
down there bobcat comes over and he goes
hey
do you want to get a picture with robin
and i was like oh my
yes dude i never asked for a picture i'm
like please and i give my phone to
bobcat and he goes
i'm going to be in it too man
yeah dude yeah for sure and it's like
in the middle of bobcat ron williams is
the greatest greatest